we started was like zero minus i had 600
pounds actually 600 pounds
you're in debt hey what's up guys
welcome back to my channel and in this
video you are going to learn all about
service accommodation rent to rent but
also what it takes to be a successful
business owner a successful property
investor i've got a couple of very
successful property entrepreneurs with
me in my house they're from czechos
republic they're living in scotland and
they've come all the way to
buckinghamshire to share their story to
help impart their wisdom and inspiration
to you so if you enjoy my youtube
channel please do me a massive favor hit
the like button that would be really
really really cool stay tuned until the
end of the video because this is going
to be a really really good one so
firstly vincent and andre thank you so
much for coming down all the way from
scotland and uh it's massive
congratulations on all you've done thank
you very much thank you yeah thank you
for having me so how did you guys meet
and when did you decide you wanted to
get into property so
we've met actually i mean we are kind of
family so he married my sister all right
so you guys are brother-in-laws
and what's your background like what's
your occupation prior to property i know
now you're really successful in property
full-time in the industry but what's
your background i mean i work in a
hospitality for quite a long time when i
came here obviously i had to work on my
english and so on i think from instance
i was similar but then he yeah so i was
i was a chef after
like a waiter manager and after i opened
my street food business my cafe but all
of that it wasn't leading me anywhere
where i wanted like more like you know
freedom with time i was spending more
time in the business
and after i had the two children so i
had to decide you know to change you
know the life
so and after you know firstly reading
some book from robert kiyosaki so i
decided to start in property journey so
you were working you had your own
business but then you kind of realized
that it was actually you owned a job yes
and you're working crazy hours um and
it's really interesting a lot of people
you know they they start a business and
they realize that actually it might be
easier to have a job than to have you
know to be self-employed i know my mom
was like a mobile hairdresser and uh you
know she worked
you know crazy hard and sometimes it's
like a lot of business owners are on
less than the minimum wage so i don't
know how successful was it were you
making good money or just working crazy
hard you've been as a chef in the
restaurant so we were working
disciplined but i mean as a business it
wasn't it wasn't too too good yeah yeah
yeah so i had to be there a lot
obviously and it's more like i started a
business not as a business it's more
like it was because i had a passion for
cooking and being a chef and when you do
something just for a passion and not
think too much in the in the future
about that so you're going to kind of
get stuck with that because you have a
high standard and it's very difficult to
find someone yeah yeah in fact robert
kiyosaki talks about this he talks about
um
and it's really interesting because a
lot of people say do what you love but
he says don't do what you love do what
needs to be done and and it's alright
thinking about your passion but you also
need to think about profit so
after reading rich dad poor dad robert
kiyosaki's book is that what kind of
gave you the desire to get into property
was that what kind of kickstarted you
yeah i mean definitely i learned a lot
but i think vincent was the one who
pushed me into it
because obviously when vincent had this
fuse business so i was kind of working
working with them with my sister as well
and then i was a bit fed up of it so i
ran away to the iceland so i spent uh
a few months there but then i came back
eventually and vincent said that he's
going
um to glasgow i believe um on one
property course and he's like if i want
to go with him i was like well okay i
can try and that's how it basically all
yeah started and did you guys have like
money to invest at this point
no no no i'm in debt
i'm still in debt paying the all the
businesses because i had to put money
into the businesses when i bought the
coffin of all of that to take the loans
and obviously it was for a longer time
so i still own the debt so when we
started it was like zero minus i had 600
pounds actually 600 pounds
you're in debt
okay and we're going to get to where you
are now because i know now you're in a
very good financial position and you've
done remarkably well which we're going
to get to how you've done that so the
first property strategy that you chose
was buy refurbished refinance rent and
you did a deal and it took a long time
and you had a lot of headaches
tell me about that deal
uh so from the beginning went pretty
smooth i mean we like i said we went on
this uh three days course in in glasgow
um they were like pushing us into the uh
their academy and so on uh
that time we refused to take any further
education and so on so it's like okay
we'll jump straight away into it so we
bought a property on the auction
by coincidence actually because we
didn't have a time to go actually
physically on the auction so we done it
through the proxy building i think uh
some intents are like okay our octopus
will be 22 000 was it
and and that's it so in the morning we
we woke up we went to the somewhere we
were driving through the cafe actually i
think at that point and when i missed a
phone call on the phone so obviously
uh internship what is it and they said
like oh you won
the the the auction
and you're like okay did you have any
money no yeah just i mean we have the 4
000 for the deposit and for the auction
fee on the account and when we check the
morning the account so it wasn't there
so they said we had 28 days to come up
with 20 900 or something like that and
we had we had just thousands and we had
28 days and we were like
oh well junior starts
crazy that's a really bold move and one
that i personally probably wouldn't
recommend yes
that people do bidding on auction
properties without any money it's kind
of risky um so where did you get the
money from so it was the stressful month
yeah like super stressful every week we
were going for meetings with friends and
with different people yeah and uh
wrongly asking for money for to invest
into that deal
because nobody believed us because we've
been both from hospitality chefs so
we're like what are you gonna do in a
property we don't no no no no no no all
the time
and we had like we need to do it because
even this eight thousand which they took
the the first day it wasn't ours it was
already from someone
so we had to make it work so we were
pushing so high so you borrowed eight
grand to put down the deposit and then
you had to get the rest of the money
but you didn't have it that must have
been stressed
but you know what that's where you grow
as well though so you managed to get
through it so you got the money and you
uh refurbed the property how much did it
cost in total to refurb uh 43
to a big refurb and then the end value
yeah okay 200 000 a year nice 100 grand
so you're able to pull your money out
that's good what was it that made you
realize that you didn't want to continue
just doing that strategy solely why did
you decide to start doing rent to rent
service accommodation lease options
well we wanted to focus on a quick cash
also because then we realized that okay
we thought that maybe you know we should
go ahead with the better if we should
have financed it would be to interrupt
you but it was actually on the crash
course i think or somewhere where we've
been
and you talk about that and we really
realized that you said like quick money
quick cash and slow
quick and cash casual need to do the
both and because of the robert kiyosaki
and what we were doing we were we
realized that we are doing just a slow
money
and we eventually are struggling with
the quick cash right so after when you
when we heard that from you we're like
oh yeah we need to focus on the quick
cash which we didn't yeah yeah so this
was the first utilization yeah yeah and
that's the thing actually it's
interesting because
being a property investor is slow it
takes time even buying a house
i mean you bought it from auction that's
the fastest way to do it but generally
speaking it's gonna take a few months
and then and then refurbing takes a few
months how long did the whole process
beginning to end with your little brr
deal take i mean so i mean from the
little project it actually became a
pretty big deal i mean because we had so
many struggles with the builders as well
yeah uh which we learned a lot uh on the
very first deal we basically had any
possible outcomes and so on so in this
deal we are talking about one and a half
years one and a half years
and then after one and a half years
you've finally got your money back and
you can pay your investors back how much
rent are you getting
750 750 to rent profits 430. 430. so 430
pounds profit which is great but that's
taken a year and a half
you could make that much profit on one
rental rent really quickly and this is
what i said to you at the i think it was
in newcastle at the property millionaire
intensive when it was like look man
you've and i even said to you at the
time i was like you've done really well
what you've done on this brr deal huge
respect do you remember this i was like
really well done but it's so slow and to
become financially free doing that it's
gonna take years and years and years a
lot of stress a lot of time you should
do that but at the same time
do
deal selling rent to rent service
accommodation so um since that
conversation i know we've done we did
some training but what happened next
we've done your course for reception
agreements we were sending letters came
here for the discovery day with you i
think it was a year and a half ago i
think
uh so
yeah that was actually first opportunity
we could actually buy some course from
you uh which was the exhaustion
agreement uh so we managed to learn some
step by step basically uh yeah guide how
to how to obtain one and so on and from
that program did you manage to get at
least option yes i mean uh we definitely
use the the letters that you suggested
there you know so we keep sending the
letters out we managed to get some deal
in bradford out from it so it was also
good uh we adjusted them a little bit so
it suits our needs you know for exactly
the house houses that we are looking for
yeah uh but yeah and it worked well i
mean we approached the the landlords and
so on and we managed to get a deal order
video that's amazing huge respect and
you've got i think you've got a second
one as well so we managed to secure two
leagues of sunday monday in one month
what if anyone doesn't anyone who's
thinking what the heck is the least
option just break it down for me what
does it mean a lease option agreement
how does it work so basically you
buy the house now but you're gonna pay
it later only thing what you need to pay
is solicitors to draw the contract so
and the important fingers on that is
like whatever you greet the price now
you're gonna buy it in a few years times
which is very good and these leaves
options would be take they've been
obviously i mean they don't have to be
but they've been in negative equity yeah
so they've been happy with the
with our proposal and we managed to get
the one day lease option agreement for
seven years and the other one for ten
years wow so it gives us a lot of time
to
to you know save for the deposit and
whatever and buy it but we also have the
agreement we can buy it at any time
during the time yeah so if the prices
would go up and it would be hundred
thousand now so we can just buy tomorrow
so it will make sense for us to just use
the situation
great what solicitors did you use for
that one of your recommended did you get
a restriction on the title deeds and
stuff like what happens if the ones if
the if the seller decides to change
their mind talk right so they they
shouldn't off because they are aware of
what everything is happening yeah they
can't they were represented by a
solicitor you represent by a solicitor
you've got it you've got the you if the
sisters done a good job which i know
they will have done there'll be a
restriction on the title dudes that says
that if they want to sell it they have
to sell it to you and if you want to buy
it they have to say yes what happens if
you don't want to buy it
well it's just the option of the buyer
so i mean we don't we don't have to i
mean so you don't have to buy but they
do have to sell yes okay that's why we
do it in england only because in
scotland it's a different rules correct
because we are in scotland so we are
thinking about this also in scotland but
it's more strict because you need to buy
it after yeah you must are you making um
cash flow from them as well yeah it's
not it's just two single lets from one
it's uh one is also on a joint venture
because we also we are always using
other people money because we are we
don't have any
so the one is bringing 100 and i think
20 pound and the other one is bringing
230 pounds
because the other one is uh from private
investors also okay well because we
don't have to put anything in it
so it's normally down everything is no
money down from our size all the deals
that's crazy so you've got these two
properties you've got the capital
appreciation of the properties you've
also got a little bit of cash flow
coming in each month but you've done it
with zero money so what happened next in
january we decided in 2021 he started
with deal sourcing so we were trying
really hard three months
and we sold none nothing yeah i mean we
didn't have any training or anything but
we sold nothing and we realized that our
investor list of 60 people is maybe not
enough
we were saying to coasters but uh we
also figured out that maybe the
locations where we are looking it's not
really working so not we didn't give up
on that but we postpone it and we're
like let's find some rent to rent deal
and after uh
watching your videos uh by then we still
didn't have the course when i've been on
every use of money again okay so you've
paid it's done yes this is what we what
we why i realized a lot of things after
so we've done
i remember i have written 26 viewings
and 26 rejections and 27 was yes for our
first generation deal is in durham
actually
um which
which we were like because we it was
something new for us we were like
you know we want to make sure it's going
to be bringing money because we have
commitments and we again did from
investors money so we need to make sure
yeah so and it was in may and after i
visited your never use over money and
brr in september
and
you said questions like so how many of
these you need to be financially free
and in my head was like yeah
i don't need that many actually why i
don't have more it was june july august
september was like four months and this
was actually working so i was like why i
didn't do more
and when you said that i came uh so you
said like how you know write your goals
so i put there that i want to do six in
the next three months because you said
three months goal and after call your
partner
i did call him and
and in the sixth month in the three
months i didn't quite manage to get uh
six but we managed to get
six in uh four months and
three were like investors got investors
so three for us and three for investors
which was actually six nice so so now
then you've got how many renter rents do
you have that's yours for her and then
you've also got some others which you're
managing for some investors how many of
those
three
so in total seven but four of them are
yours
and roughly how much profit per month
per property are you making in average
we would be around 400 pounds per
property
uh because some of them are joint
ventures again because we are not using
any of our money right so you're sharing
the profits we are sharing the profit so
you're making less monthly money than
you would but you put in nothing yeah we
put nothing yeah yeah yes so and
diminished uh you know also you know so
some property would make a little bit
more something a little bit less but in
average four hundred dollars
so how much are you making in total then
at the moment with all your properties
and everything what's what sort of
income are you getting so we are getting
from single ads like thousands from rent
to lens 3000 plus we sell roughly now
because we started resourcing in june
again so we sell like one deal a month
around 2000. nice
so all together i mean that's that's
quite that's certainly a lot more than
an average job yeah so it's around six
dollars
and you started with absolutely nothing
and you've used other people's money
that's incredible and and and what would
you say i mean
advice would you give to someone that's
starting with nothing because some
people think that it's not possible
because
it sounds too good to be true doesn't it
like you've only been in the game for
sort of 18 months or so
that's not that long if if
you know starting from nothing zero
money to think that you've accumulated
all these properties you've got two
lease options four rents are rents three
three under management a brr
like
it's it's really impressive with nothing
have you used any of your own money no
not really no i mean if you don't have
them you can't
you know this is the push if you don't
have them you can't use them right so
what what would you say
has made it possible for you because i
know i know um we were speaking earlier
about mindset and things like that and
about the difference between people that
win and people that lose is actually
mindset but what advice would you give
to somebody starting out that's got no
money that wants to follow in your
footsteps i guess you have to have goals
no we have to pursue them and also
surround yourself with people that
actually either done it or
or they can at least show you how to do
it or yeah that's i think what i would
say i think the money shouldn't be
objections for someone to start
improperly yeah if they think that they
need money to make money like objection
so they will never start you know it
doesn't matter how much money they have
i think if they know it can be done so
they need to just start and some a lot
of people are just overthinking all the
process you know they are thinking about
the step i don't know
the ef but they are not taking the
action for step a so if they are willing
to take the first
action in step a so the rest is going to
come up like we did we put you know we
found first 8000 and after we put it as
a deposit and when this was agreed so
we're like now we need to do it yeah
because if you wouldn't take the first
step you never know where it's gonna
lead so i think the a lot of people
they are still getting a lot of
knowledge they are learning learning but
they are not taking any action yeah they
need to take the action really
interesting i mean it was actually a one
a friend of mine called anthony lavelle
who said
most people think that their problem is
that they haven't got any money
but actually the hard bit is not getting
the money the hard bit is getting to the
point where you need the money yeah
because you might think oh i need three
grand for a rental rent i haven't got
three grand but actually
just go and find a rent around that's
hard enough
and then when you find one you're like
oh now i need the money
it's actually not too difficult getting
the money
how did you get the money for the
training though because you spent
thousands on
on on training programs
where did where did that money come from
again from investors
wow so when i was on your training
course uh i remember that i was texting
two people like can you lend me
thousands and for what training was
investing into myself all right and then
another person the same so they put two
thousand and i bought the course
that's how i raise i've done it on the
spot yeah pretty much yeah yeah i mean
when a friend of mine i would never
guess that uh she would actually lend me
but uh she did
uh a friend she she's a waitress i mean
an incredible person and to be honest
thanks to her all right i need to talk
to you guys about how to raise finance
because that seems to be one of your
greatest skills you know you to eight
thousand pound deposit on an auction
then the rest
money for training money for rent and
rents
how do you do this how do you get people
how do you get people to just give you
thousands and thousands of pounds
what's the agree do you have an
agreement a contract
i mean definitely we do have a contract
between each other even though there are
maybe friends and so on but obviously
everyone wants to have a secret kind of
what kind of a contract do you have we
have a simple two-page loan agreement
like how much they are giving us for how
long was the written on investment for
them signed dated and how much interest
do you give them or do you give them a
percentage of your profits percentage it
depends well yeah depends usually it's
interest basically usually it's like one
percent a month this is the i usually
like percent twenty percent of the year
yeah
one percent a month twelve percent a
year is how much you normally give and
then you borrow over how long um depends
on the project but usually
minimum like one year
yeah yeah is that not really risky i
mean if you know
what the deal you are making how much
you're going to be making to profit you
can calculate you can you know do your
research so if you know that your
entrance if the condition is going to be
making 500 a month and you know that you
need to be paying him i don't know for
example if he lend us for the deal five
thousand which is 50 pound from that
so you put 50 pound for that and you can
put money on the side for him to give
him money money back in a year so even
if the even for a year you would be just
giving the money but after you didn't
need to put any of your money and you
are just profiting i guess it's like
robert kiyosaki talks about you know
don't work for money make money work for
you so you'll be even smarter because
you're making other people's money work
for you
yeah it's also a win situation for them
because obviously there maybe we have a
savings on the site
uh but they are not doing anything for
them so obviously if you offer them some
interest on their money they they are
happy to yeah lend them to you and if
they have some questions you can always
show them the project where you are
going to invest in and if it makes sense
to them then they're obviously happy to
go ahead and i guess they're they're
kind of investing in you aren't they
really because presumably the loans that
you know they're unsecured so if if you
couldn't pay them back
then
there's very little comeback i mean they
could take you to court and they'd win
but there's it's not like they have got
a charge on a property
with the rent to rents so i guess there
there's a little bit of trust there how
do you how do you build that up how do
you how do you build relationships and
get people to a point whereby that they
believe in you so much that they're
prepared to put money into your deal
well it takes time definitely obviously
they need to know you they need to trust
you like you said so obviously it
doesn't happen overnight
vincent met many people actually on
networking events and so on uh i've also
networked with people even just through
the social medias uh some of them i have
never met in person actually but because
we are already you know for months and
years in touch they just
probably know what kind of person i am
so they just i think you start with your
family and friends around
and just asking them you know for money
and the way how you should ask you know
follow kind of a script not just like
ask like when we've done the first time
now we know how to ask more
professionally and when you start with
them so the most important is to build
creditability so people can see you so i
think it's important for people if they
are starting the property i tell it to
all my clients because i work with some
people also just to you know do social
media
you know go out there do networking
events present yourself what you do and
just be presentable so people can see
what you do because they will buy from
you yeah
and how do you ask how do you ask
professionally so what was that what
does that look like it's like you're
planting the seats with the people i
think you are saying that also on the on
the evens yes so it's more like you
don't ask them you don't ask them you
ask them for help yeah to
check the project what you have what
they think about that and if they know
kind of someone who would be willing to
invest into that project and they are
thinking that had like what the heck why
he doesn't ask me i have the money on
the account and he doesn't know but he's
the is the person we are asking for the
money
that's brilliant so you're basically
like hey i really value your opinion
i've got this project i'd love you to
look at it this is what it is i am going
to be looking for investment i need 4
000 pounds what do you think what do you
think kind of things i should be saying
to the investors and they're they're
thinking well hang on a minute i got
four thousand pounds and then
they might even just put themselves
forward and go well i might be
interested and then boom and the final
thing is i ask one family which are my
friends
like a family friends and have a
children so on and i wouldn't even think
they have money i wouldn't think they
were living like a nice life but i
wouldn't think they would have many
savings so i would i've done the same
thing with them but i literally was
asking them if they know someone i
really was asking them if they know
someone yeah and these people like i do
have this four thousand yeah next time i
ask them the same
uh like you know i know you already
invest in four thousand just would you
know anyone who would have three
thousand for this deal because i already
raised three i need three i have another
fee i was like whoa
sometimes we are thinking sometimes we
are thinking the people which they have
money and they would lend us they
wouldn't do it but the people who think
they don't have the money they actually
do that's a great tip that's a great tip
and i think
there's no rejection either because
you're not saying to them can you lend
me money and they're having to say no
so if they don't want to lend you money
they'll just go oh i'll have a think on
it and i'll let you know if i think of
anybody so there's it's not awkward
there's no rejection that's genius and
the fact that you're investing in deals
you know i've huge respect for you guys
um investing into yourselves as well
because i i think that when you invest
in yourself it makes it much easier for
other people to invest in you because
you've invested you know what you're
doing you know the numbers um how's life
changed then over the last couple of
years from now to say two years ago when
you were working as a chef and you were
running away in iceland um what's life
like now compared uh it's definitely
warmer than iceland i would say but no
no it's um
it's obviously it's different i mean we
are progressing and we still want to
grow uh
it's definitely
yeah i mean i feel a little bit more
fulfilled than before
uh i don't have to be in you know
depending on somebody's paycheck and so
on so
i'm enjoying what i'm doing and i
definitely want to develop it how about
you vincent has life changed i mean a
lot because again you know i'm i'm doing
what i want to do you know in the
property you know going for viewing
speaking with people and you know a lot
about being around like-minded people
you know if i go into networking events
or different you know um
trainings like from you i mean on your
training never use or money and vr this
is where i met a lot of joint venture
partners and they are still sending me
messages they want to do joint venture
but i don't have a deal at the moment
so there's uh so there's more money
there than there is deals available yeah
that is yeah so yeah
so i really like the the community of
people you know being around the people
because i think this is a very powerful
yes network and if you are just in your
job like you know i run the cafe so they
came to people they they left and it was
always just the you know
i don't know how to say the small chat
with the people but it wasn't really
leading anywhere you know i obviously
served them i've done some business with
them but it wasn't it wasn't fulfilling
you know i like the cooking but it
wasn't going anywhere
but now
we have a plan to you know focus and
progress more so it's like you know when
you have the right people around
yourself you can do that
that's great you guys have invested into
my training and you've got the practical
how-to skills but you've also i know
you've done a lot of stuff with um
tony robbins and i know you guys have
got really into personal development um
and you're paying it forward it's great
to see you a lot of people are talking
about how you know you've passed
inspiration to them and you're pulling
others up um how important is
personal development and
mindset in all of this as opposed to
just having the theory in the skills uh
i mean uh i really like what tony
robbins is saying he's saying like 80
percent of success it's your mindset is
your psychology and 20 are the strategy
skills and so on
and uh
what i realized in the time it's like a
lot of people are just focusing on the
knowledge and they are overthinking all
the process and rather than to be
focusing on themselves so as i mentioned
i'm working with some clients you know
through the coaching and
then they are asking me like what to do
i mean i explained them the the
the how to do their entertainment things
like that but they wouldn't still take
this action sometimes so the important
is to take the action and when they are
like what else can i do i was like read
the book yeah take a personal
development book you know and just read
it because over there you're gonna learn
so much
uh so much things which may help you in
the future you never know but you know
stop reading things which are not
important for what you want to
accomplish but just try to do something
you know because books are great because
they are the cheapest uh knowledge where
you can get you can book you can get a
book for 10 pounds and you can learn so
much not everybody have a lot of
thousands for seminars for start but
everybody can get the book so if you are
starting you can just read the books and
in a while when you're gonna grow as a
person so you know you can obviously
grow you know your business but let's go
together you cannot just grow your
business and not to grow as a person
because it wouldn't lead you anywhere so
what what why is it why is it so
important to you because i know you've
started um doing mindset coaching to
people and helping people that might be
struggling why what why do you love
doing that so much where what made you
want to start doing that recently
finally you asked because i think you
have the same
uh
i'd say um
the feeling it's because like when you
work with someone with the person and
they are succeeding and they are taking
the steps because they learn that from
you so it makes you even more happy yeah
so their success makes you more happy
than your success that's great and it's
it's so good that when you start
succeeding and getting to the top of the
mountain it's so good to then pull other
people up with you and help other people
whether that be inspiring them or
recommending books to them or like what
you're doing and coaching them on
mindset
i think it's i think it's absolutely
fantastic what's the plan then on the
property front from here what are you
what are you wanting to do over the next
sort of few months and years uh so right
now i mean we we launched for example
the the management company for your
entrance and reinsurance service
accommodations
so definitely want to sculpt this one up
we would like to expand uh
you know at the moment we have most of
the properties in scotland
uh so we want to definitely scale up so
we will be probably covering bigger
areas and so on
that's one side so i'm definitely
focusing on that at the moment and
definitely we want to
yeah
systematize systematize
the
um
and the
the sourcing of the deals and so on yeah
uh so
yeah
so basically just more of the same but
just scale it and and grow it and make
more money
yeah and what was it that made you agree
to come down all the way from scotland
to my house in beckensfield to do this
interview
i mean we got the invitation from you we
were chatting on the facebook you said
we should come so i started to chat just
with your
team
about the opportunity so i mean it's
great to be you know with you and around
again like around people like my little
and be around someone like you it's like
always good so why not
well i really appreciate you coming down
and it's been a real pleasure to have
seen your success and if there's
anything you need for me moving forward
give me a shout
what will be your final words of wisdom
and advice to someone watching the video
um that's just starting out final words
of wisdom go invest into yourself i
guess i would say don't be afraid to
take the action take a massive action
right now when you shot the video just
go do it
well guys thank you so much for coming
down folks i hope you enjoyed that two
pieces of advice from these guys that
are actually doing it that have been
there done it got the t-shirt started
from nothing is invest in yourself and
take massive action right now if you
want to come down to the property
investors crash course
it's completely free there are limited
tickets available but if you want to
come down there's a link in the
description so get booked on if you want
to connect with these wonderful people
i'm also going to leave their details
also in the description that i've done
over a hundred interviews like this in
fact way more every every week for the
last three years i've been interviewing
people on winners on a wednesday there's
an entire playlist right here check it
out subscribe get down to the property
investors crash course and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you